you said you were robbed and it changed
you oh yeah I was robbed a couple of
times I was robbed
the first time I was robbed I was robbed
I was doing a I was in Reid I was doing
a plate on the east side of Detroit
which is crazy
it's much better than I put it the
theater was on the east side of Detroit
and my car was out of course so I had to
catch two buses to get home and I was
standing at the bus stop waiting for the
bus which it's not like here or
somewhere like a subway train running
every two minutes and Detroit it's like
I told it's like Mad Max in the
Thunderdome you got there late you know
so I was waiting for the bus and it was
kind of cold and I was like this you
know and and I felt somebody and I kind
of heard somebody coming from this side
and I kind of said don't look over I
like oh it stuck something in my side
and he wasn't a finger cuz it felt like
steel he said okay give me your money I
said okay alright but I don't really
have no money so what you talking about
you know ain't no money I don't have any
money I got some little change and I got
a bus ticket that's all I get what
you're doing over here and I said I'm
rehearsing a play I'm an actor and
refreshing the show now he engaged me
that long and he said well give me what
you got nothing I like 32 citizen you
said that all you got I said yeah how's
it don't shoot me
I said I'm just trying to make it and he
said alright alright soon and he said
just don't don't I don't move I said I'm
not I'm not gonna do nothing and he
started walking off and I kind of saw
him and I said don't you want the bus
ticket and he looked at me and I saw him
I look right at him at that point he
says no fool
how you gonna get all
and that was like so really what I saw
after that and I felt with that whole
situation was that was somebody that
lived around there that probably has
seen me before but people don't just
randomly walk up to somebody and the
funny thing is after that I didn't tell
anybody
well I wasn't about to tell my mom and
then whoa hell no and I was going with a
little girl each time I wouldn't tell
her so I was like no I just didn't ever
say nothing but the first thing somebody
would says you can't go back over there
I'm like no no it's a good party show
okay and I knew I was hooked there I'm
like home looked nobody ever bothered me
after that because this guy probably
told all them around there
yeah no money your actor over here at
this place leave him alone
nobody ever bother you that really woke
me up too late Wow
this is what I really want on this
dedicated but it's like when my friends
say if they don't shoot you that was
that kind of situation where it's like
okay you either do this or you get shot
so I'm like I'm not gonna stop coming
over here now somebody else might rob me
and I hope to have a few more coins in
my pocket but I was broke I mean I would
literally broke so I was like I had like
32 sentence something in the bus ticket
because you know we had bus tickets you
get a stripper bus tickets and you know
you get a transfer when you get on the
bus and I had a got to transfer with the
bus ticket and second time I got robbed
was in a McDonald's I was living I
wasn't doing a show at the time but I
was living on the other side of town and
my dad was sick in the hospital and my
mother and I actually had my car at that
point and my mother was at the hospital
all day she said well you know what I'm
I just don't feel good you know being at
the house by myself can you come over
and spend the night at Towson oh of
course
hey long apartment that's oh yeah so she
said well look I've been at the hospital
all day I don't have no food I haven't
cooked maybe you ought to stop at
McDonald's
something get you something I said oh
okay and I stopped at the McDonald's I
went through the drive-through his
current late at night and I ordered my
food and the girl said well can you pull
over cuz you know we're cooking and
bringing out to you I said okay so I'm
sitting in the car that's cold I'm
running my gas I'm like oh wait a minute
so I said well I'm gonna go inside so I
came inside and she's like I said I'm
the guy you told the pullover she's oh
okay
so they said we haven't even got it
ready yet so so I'm stand at the counter
and there's like four of us four guys at
the counter you know getting our food
and the little boy in front of me you
know the little McDonald's boy he's like
looking at me and all of a sudden he
looks over like this and he starts doing
this and I'm looking at him like look
you got I'm looking like he's it and I
look over guy got a sawed-off shotgun
pointed right at my head and he's
telling me raise your hands [ __ ]
my hands up and these guys proceeded to
rob the McDonald's and what he did was
it was - one guy came in on the other
side the other door the backup guy and
he uses me as a shield and he's got the
gun under my arm like my arms up he puts
the gun under here and he's got the gun
right in the face of that little boy and
he says empty the register and the
little boy and naturally uh he's an
empty the register so the manager of
female at this time she's down here and
the guy with the sawed-off he says okay
empty all the registers she empties all
the registers except mine and then he
said okay open the safe and she says
well I can't I don't have a combination
that's a drop box you say no you can
open the safe she says I can't open it
they come every night and get the money
the security come every night get the
money I can't open it he said you lie he
says get out on the ground [ __ ] she
gets down on the ground on the florida
other place and he leans over the
counter and he [ __ ] the gun
puts it on the side he says I'm gonna
tell you I'm ask you one last time open
the safe
so she's like this and she's a she
starts crying please don't kill me I
can't hoping to save I got a baby at
home please just me and my baby please
please and I'm like this and I'm just
looking and I'm just like oh my god and
I got to got behind me with the little
boy like this and I'm like this and I'm
like oh I'm like this and all of a
sudden the guy uncocks the gun and the
next thing on my mind is thank God be
professionals professionals don't want
to shoot anybody see I found that out
from being in Detroit around the hood
what professionals don't shoot anybody
they want to get in and get out so he
says ok we're finished getting the money
she jumps up she gets the money she gets
down to my register little boy money and
we said give him the money
give him the money we yelling and
screaming and they said shut up we
didn't shut up give me the money give
him the money
it was just pandemonium so this manager
she knocks him out the way goes in his
register and get the money put it in one
of the big McDonald's bags and hand it
to the guy so the first guy out of the
place is the guy that had to piss to
undermine the last guy out he says
anybody trying saying I'll come back and
kill everybody he comes down on the line
of us didn't rob us he comes down the
line of us and takes to the gun across
all our backs smaller my back I had this
gun go down the small of my back and I'm
telling you my life flash before my eyes
when people say all my life slash I went
from being a baby [ __ ] my pants in
my diaper all the way up to the it was
just like that I'm like oh and I'm like
oh god oh oh like this and he left out
when he left out he took off running I
looked they took over and all of the
customers jumped over the counter and we
would all be anything by this time the
cops came in cuz they put they push the
silent alarm
and I got to the house and my mother
said oh she said you didn't get your
food I'm like no I didn't get it so she
says I what's wrong I said we got stuck
up in McDonald's
my mother's like oh okay my mother got
mad at me when I said I have to remember
what that felt like because one day I'm
gonna have to act and have to recreate
that experience my mother got mad at me
but that's what happened what you and
that damn acting and that's what I
really finally realized this is it this
is where I was going to be that was the
first experience of me getting robbed
with the guy with the gun take my load
$0.32 the second one was that and that's
when I said I'm in all the way because
all I'm thinking about at one point
during the robbery is like I am this
this is weird I got I have to remember
this I just did a thing on shooter TV
show shooter where I play the bank guard
and I get shot in the in the episode and
they put a squid back home and
everything they lied to me oh is it not
gonna hurt it's gonna be just said it
would learn the answer that squid hurt
and I get shot in the scene and I fall
over but I but but even though I'm like
and I'm belligerent to the guy he says
all right oh man
cuz the flashback from the early 70s or
whatever and in it's a flashback scene
so I said well I didn't I didn't I
didn't lady I said get on the grounds
here my back here I got a bad hip and a
bad back I can't get down there he said
I told you to get on the ground I said I
can't do it if I didn't laid out in
Korea I'm not laying down now so he
shoots me but at that point I'm
recalling a lot of that experience of
that and we did one take and the
director says that was so real and we
broke for lunch and he says that was wow
I looked at it that was that was real I
said yeah I said I told him the story at
mcdonnell's he says what I said yeah
I've been stuck up a couple of time man
I've been shot at before all kind of
stuff it's like you trying to write a
passage it's like you know
Bar Mitzvah is like get shot get stabbed
and stabbed yeah I got stabbed in the
girls prison
yeah worked it 100 I said what were you
doing there I was a I was working as a
telling with my last job
you